donnez jean olharan bonsoir
avoir enflammé tous les stades de foot
d'europe david ginola alias el magnifico
est aujourd'hui le nouvel animateur
vedette de m6 david ginola 1 messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'été
david ginola donc
une anecdote sur cette photo parce
qu'elle a été faite par mario testino
marqués par l'époque où poser nue pour
c'était pour le magazine glamour dans
les années 90 et il a fait une
exposition à londres dans un musée et je
me suis retrouvée entre la princesse de
galles et madonna j'étais le seul qui
était nu sur les photos que magnifique
alors el magnifico c'est bien mais ça a
bien failli être l cardiaque au
el qaria celle là je la fais moi que
vous nous avez raconté la dernière le
jour où vous étiez mort
neuf minutes victime d'un arrêt
cardiaque alors que vous disputez un
match de foot avec des potes à mandelieu
la napoule à canal et à cannes oui c'est
la banlieue de cannes calais à cannes
m pokora vous a sans doute sauvé la vie
dans le conte en vous faisant un massage
cardiaque et vous êtes obligé d'aimer
les chansons de m pokora non non a fait
en fait il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
été dites il y à du deux personnes qui
se sont relayés pour me faire un massage
cardiaque
c'est frédéric mendy et pierrick
bourgeat et quand les ambulanciers sont
arrivés qui m'ont fait utiliser le
défibrillateur pour me choquer au bout
de cinq fois mon coeur est reparti donc
cinq fois quand même mais mais mais en
fait la véritable histoire cce qui m'ont
sauvé la vie d'accord ce que même si le
chirurgien aurait pu grimper aux rideaux
leader en fait non c'est pas ça c'est
qu'en fait on a voulu tisser une
histoire autour de 2 de ceux de cet
événement avec avec justement le niveau
de personnalités d'aider des gens et on
s'est dit que finalement m matt pokora
la personne qui sauvait david ginola
c'était quelque chose qui pouvait mieux
on a eu des gens mauvais mais il a bien
motivés jo sur j'aime j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup le garçon et lui aussi a
souffert quelque peu aussi de ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui répondre à des gens qui
viennent me dire bravo pour ce que vous
avez fait en sachant que finalement vous
n'avez pas pas les réellement c'est
quand même aurait exactement alors ce
qui s'est passé je crois qu'on peut le
dire aux téléspectateurs vous avez vu
une grande lumière blanche vous êtes
arrivé devant un vieux monsieur barbu
qui vous a demandé c'est bien vous le
ginola qui avait privé la france de la
coupe du monde en 84 siri
vous a laissé repartir sur terre oui
parce qu'il savait que ce n'était pas de
votre faute voilà laissez-moi termine r
si
je salue on sait jamais jack a besoin de
lui dans quelques temps alors quadruples
pontage donc vous avez une cicatrice
énorme et vous la montrer aux filles en
disant vous avez fait la guerre du
vietnam sens
concernant l'accident cardiaque je
répète pour la millième fois faites vous
contrôlez c'est à dire vous possible
étions très bonne santé sauf que
malheureusement vous alliez des artères
bouchées j'imagine donc faites vous
contrôlez le plus souvent possible ces 8
millions de morts par an c'est la
deuxième cause de mortalité dans le
monde après le cancer et que aujourd'hui
suffirait de très peu pour pour changer
ça apprendre les gestes qui sauvent
voilà ça prend une à deux heures à la
protection civile à la croix rouge ou
chez les pompiers la wii et vous pouvez
sauver vous pouvez devenir un héros
celui qui m'a prodigué le massage
cardiaque pendant 9 minutes je les
appelais quelques semaines après pour le
remercier en sachant que le remerciement
en fait je ne trouvais pas les mots
parce que cet homme là m'a sauvé la vie
dire merci à quelqu'un qui vous sauve la
vie si ces choses comme s'est passé pas
suffisamment
c'est pas suffisant c'est assez
important minimum sauf qu'il m'a dit une
chose il m'a dit car je suis rentré à la
maison mon petit garçon m'a regardé et
il m'a dit papa tu as héros mais voilà
alors beaucoup joué
non bachy avec des aveugles en même
temps c'est pas dur on regarde
toi david
[Musique]
wen au but elle habite à droite mme
anthouard
[Musique]
le brut est
pierre pasqua
[Musique]
non ça s'appelle le souci foot c'est du
foot pour les non-voyants là et quand
david a joué contre l'équipe de cécifoot
il avait l'impression de jouer contre
l'om
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes beaucoup
plus zen depuis cette histoire vous dit
avant je voulais que tout le monde même
aujourd'hui je m'en fous complet complet
il y avoit de vie jean là on s'en fout
que vous vous en foutiez on vous aime
quand même
finalement c'est peut-être pour ça ouais
on est toujours dans cette quête de la
mort récente d'être aimé par le en plus
un très grand nombre de personnes et que
finalement la maturité l'expérience de
la vie vous apprend une chose c'est que
finalement un
la terre entière ne pourra pas vous
aimez et que d'une certaine manière il
faut se contenter de ce qu'on a et 2 kw
à 2 d'accord quand on dit hein il ya 1,2
pardon
oui mais le 2 décembre le jazz le 2
c'est que la vie n'est donnée que plus
belle malgré deux bons jeux alors
aujourd'hui vous iriez boire un verre
avec gérard houllier qui vous avait
descendu en 94 mais vous dites quand
même j'irai boire un verre avec lui mais
bon le vert il termine pas forcément
dans la gorge non alors j'ai là pour
parler de ça parce que je peux en parler
à vos mains avec une certaine sérénité 1
je ne vais plus m'encombrer d'aller avec
les gens je ne vais plus m'encombrer
d'aller passer du temps avec des gens
qui ne le méritent pas ou que je n'aime
pas c'est à dire que le temps qui passe
je vais le passer avec des gens qui à
mes yeux sans des gens importants voilà
c'est tout c'est pato n'y a pas de deux
y a pas d'accord alors s'il ya pas deux
arrêtes de dire ça suffit maintenant
alors aujourd'hui je suis prêt
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai vous passez
des heures à admirer la montagne de la
sainte-victoire par exemple ce que vous
n'auriez jamais fait avant vous êtes
devenus plus contemplatif je les ai
toujours été voilà je peux passer des
heures au jardin regarder à regarder la
mer je veux passer des heures à regarder
la montagne devant et je suis prêt je
dis toujours été comme contemplatif j'ai
toujours eu cette cet amour de 2,2
et puis à la télé vous voilà animateur
de télé alors la france a un incroyable
talent j'imagine que mes n'avait aucun
commentaire à faire sur la sphère rozon
non on va laisser la justice travailler
j'ai appris la nouvelle la chaîne a
décidé de suspendre l'émission
pour des raisons d'éthique et je crois
que voilà c'est le moi je ne sais pas
plus laisser faire la justice c'est très
courageux de la part de m6 alors que
cinq prime time était tournée mettre à
la poubelle je trouve ça assez bien de
la part de m6 oui puis je viens de dire
moi je ne sais pas suffisamment moi non
plus pour faire déjà un des commentaires
et deuxièmement je pense que la justice
la justice va faire son travail sera
plus alors bon il ya la france a un
incroyable talent mais là aussi les
shows musicaux que j'étais venu quand un
jeu trop ce sont des choses que je ne
pensais pas du tout être capable de
faire
j'avoue que j'ai un arc avec beaucoup
beaucoup de corps déjà retrouvés à
vous-même j'étais capable de le faire et
sa mort georges et surtout de prouver à
beaucoup à beaucoup de gens surtout chez
m6 ouais genre asie l'histoire riche et
m6 et ses garçons conditions
alors bien c'est les 40 ans du puy du
fou alors la réunion à la ddt vous vous
êtes déguisé en gladiateurs pour ça
c'est une sacrée expérience ouais je
tiens à le dire j'ai découvert un
endroit extraordinaire que je ne
connaissais pas du tout philippe de
villiers quand il a bâti cet empire
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est un empire il
ya 40 ans
ne pensez pas avec son petit spectacle
arriver à ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui ils
ont réussi à baisser le taux de chômage
dans le pays est incroyablement
justement parce qu'ils n'employaient au
départ que des vendeurs est arrivé là
bas et voir la qualité des spectacles
mais j'insiste là dessus sur les
chorégraphies j'ai appris ma
chorégraphie de deux minutes trente ans
gladiateurs je joue le rôle de maximus
et on est quatre gladiateurs on se bat
devant cinq six mille personnes puisque
c'était une sorte de mini coliseum
ouais c'était il y avait de bien délire
où il ya des manifs on va regarder à
quoi ça ressemble
philippe etchebest
ophélie meunier
david ginola
jérôme anthony
julien ménielle cinq animateurs de m6
vont découvrir d'une façon totalement
inédite
l'avis des professionnels qui font
chaque jour le spectacle au puy du fou
ils vont avoir 48 heures pour
s'entraîner et prendre leur place je tu
ils deviennent un gladiateur
ils vont devoir se surpasser voilà il
faut absolument pas regarder le rejoint
[ __ ] c'est vraiment très très haut je
sais pas comment vous faire
j'ai peur de faire tout foiré on va le
faire c'est pas comment on va le faire
du sport ils vont vivre une aventure
humaine unique
papara
[Musique]
ce soir les animateurs font le spectacle
le mental dans le mental
qu'est ce que tu as fait j'ai tout donné
[Musique]
hu
c'est qui qui m'a tuer
[Musique]
oui
mais
et voilà bravo
[Applaudissements]
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus